turning overseas this morning Australian
police are praising bystanders who
helped end a deadly stabbing spree in
Sydney a man is accused of stabbing at
least two people and trying to attack
others in the city's financial district
overnight one woman is dead
police have not determined a motive but
say the suspect has a history of mental
illness
Lachlan Kennedy from our partner Network
ten in Australia is at the crime scene
this is usually one of the busiest
intersections in the heart of Sydney
city and today it was in lockdown this
afternoon when a man wearing a balaclava
and holding a large knife marched down
one of the streets before attacking a
woman who was sitting in a bar slashing
her in the back before running up this
street and jumping on the Front's of
cars at these traffic lights it was then
when members of the public saw him they
decided to gave give chase they ran
after him down another Street and when
they eventually got him they held him
there until police arrived
by using cut chairs from a coffee shop
and a milk crate placing it on his head
until police got there now it was only
after that man was arrested a 21 year
old from Western Sydney that police
sadly discovered a second crime scene a
21 year old woman stabbed to death in a
nearby apartment block the motives for
this attack are unknown but police say
they did find a USB stick near the man
on it there was information about mass
killing events including the
Christchurch massacre while they say say
at this stage while the man does have a
known history of mental illness he has
no known links to terrorism Gail thank
you very much Lachlan Kennedy from our
partner Network ten in Australia